Pull the trigger, dispense the nail and whack it in a one hit. So what you're telling me is goodbye
conventional hammer? Goodbye  conventional life! Hello nail hammer!
Ran out of gas you'll only ever get a little bit of gas at a time hey you noticed
I'd I like to come by and see it. I'd like seeing you as well
I was hoping to save up to taking dinner someplace nice. I would love that
Yeah, get whatever you want by the way this one's on me
I've been thinking about this ever since I first got gas at your place. You must be so excited about all your shows.
do you mean to tell me with no money down I can buy a house. For pennies on the dollar!
Do you know what this Tillerman TV show we keep seeing this guy's everywhere
We need to know who this man is and we need him on this show
I'm sorry about all these cheap dates
This TV stuff. I'm just a little out of it, but you know the clapper yeah, but I'm gonna bounce back
What is that your head is about to explode?
That's my head you can take that off all right computer. Somebody's making money off, and it ain't us
I subtract you like five bucks right now just for watching that
You Recognize this man right here, yeah
Do you know the clapper
Judy so people came by tonight asking all kinds of questions. They'd a photograph of you. You're in trouble no
I'm not in trouble. I like you Eddie. I really do wonder, but I need my job like I need my job
How'd you get this number night every night? We want you in the show. I'm not comfortable
Do you not television anywhere it stop harassing my girl? Where's Judy?
Things got out of control, and I didn't know how to handle it
The clapper it's great to finally meet you
I mean you wanna make a big joke out of me go ahead
I just lost the only person that matter through this whole thing I
Can't tell you how nice lists good things could come out of this
We didn't do it again. Don't look at me look at the camera you looking at me. Don't look at me
I know I'm talking you, but don't look at me. Don't look at me look at the camera. You look at me again